to go they have asked you to leave three
times three times after well I'm sorry
come on jail time no no no we're going
to jail what are you doing what do you
have to do don't you
okay putting these in here come on come
on come on come up Missy Missy what
you're not wearing any pants now you
come I got my pants ones you want how
about these these are good these are
darling
please I don't want to wear those I
don't think that's mine
this is charity that I want to wear her
stupid skirt panties wait a second this
is on back what did you forget
my cell phone where is it
in the bar are you lying to me
you come back here in the car you can
okay let's smoke one first cuz I just
have to wait for I'm waiting for a phone
call inside like yes of course I do
now we're gonna be good we're gonna be
friends we're not gonna run we're not
gonna puke right
no no no son of a bitch she tricked me
goes a trek there's a little genius
[Music]